many animals do it's often part of their
grooming routines and can help them form
bonds
yes really in fact scientists at the
California Institute of Technology have
just discovered a rare group of sensory
neurons that respond to stroking but not
other kinds of touch in mice in David
Anderson's lab no you can't go his team
have been studying the jungle of nerve
endings under the skin to work out which
ones respond to stroking and which ones
respond to other kinds of touch like
poking the team used fluorescent tags
the tags glow when the neurons are
active well first they had to test their
method so they artificially stimulated
the neurons using chemicals and it
worked then they pinched poked and
stroked the mice on their hind paws
alright then the researcher saw one
group of neurons light up when they
strokes and a different group light up
when they poked and pinched that's what
the scientists wanted to know so they
set up a test on day one they shot the
mice in room a and gave them a drug that
stimulated their stroking neurons on day
2 they shut the mice in rooms C and gave
them saline solution designed to have no
effect they alternated between rooms for
several days then on the test day they
put the mice in the middle kept the
doors open and let them run freely them
I spent most time in room a oh sorry the
drug only works on their lab mice
stroking neurons seem to be wired to
produce a pleasurable sensation when
they're activated that's why the mice
preferred room a the experiment shows
that stroking is positively reinforcing
or rewarding which might explain why
animals enjoy grooming
well since you're a hairy mammal like a
mouse it's likely that you've got a
similar group of neurons that respond
when your own strokes you maybe we
aren't as hairy as mice but we like
massages the end of the mouse neurons
looks suspiciously like a receptor found
underneath the hairy parts of our skin
so maybe all mammals have stroking
neurons